he is the manager of the world champion
los angeles dodgers kind enough to call
back into this program
he is dave roberts congratulations skip
rich my man how are you doing i am doing
fine
how are you doing i'm doing well i'm uh
i'm actually uh been quarantining uh you
know obviously uh and i don't
know we're going to talk about it this
is just turner thing so now we all got
to kind of
go back to our homes and quarantine
until the 11th so i'm kind of
laying low which is actually not a bad
thing well it's like it seems like every
time
i talk to you there's there is something
going on uh last time was when
you know there was a double header up in
san francisco that you were either gonna
do or you weren't because of what was
going on with covet 19 and all that
stuff and
but at least it wound up with you uh
getting that championship
and i i that's that that is where i'd
like to start with you first and
what you think it means to you as the
manager of the los
angeles dodgers to finally deliver that
trophy to this franchise with all the
pressures
that comes with the gig you know what
richard two words that uh
that uh you know you just mentioned that
kind of resonate with me is
finally and pressure um
you know i i think that you know in my
position
in my dna i don't really let that bleed
into my
job um because i feel like it'll be
compromised on a day to day
i'm always kind of looking out looking
forward to the next day
but after that last out was made i think
that the finality of it
the pressure that kind of seeped in
ultimately kind of showed itself and
i feel a lot more relieved than i do
overjoyed which i don't know if it's a
bad thing a good thing but i do think
that the joy
uh will kind of show itself even more
but i guess i just didn't appreciate the
pressure
that i was under that i put myself on
whatever it might be
um but i'm just so excited for the
organization the fans and all that
um to win a championship yeah and and it
just
again the the the amount of uh
production that you got from so many
players i mean it wasn't just one two it
was
pretty much your entire lineup up and
down as as we saw
um you know corey seeger being the mvp
mookie betts is out of his mind just in
terms of his talent
um so on and so forth uh but that game
four
loss you know you're called a manager
for a reason you're not a coach you're a
manager you have to manage
everything not just pitch count not just
this that but
but um humans as well um
what were you what did you do after that
that what did you actually utilize
in your in your arsenal to try and
help turn the page there so successfully
yeah you know what i i think for me
it was um you know i i think it was just
continuing to remain positive
and uh there was something i did uh and
it was noted and i brought it to light
is uh pedro bis came in gave up a homer
went back out after i told him he was
done and
gave another homer and we ended up
losing that game um
but i think for me is that i wanted to
kind of clear the air with him and just
take ownership that it was whether it
did impact or not that second inning
um just say that take ownership and say
apologize to that publicly
and i think that that resonated with our
clubhouse because some people heard i
said he was down
and to go back out there and for their
leader to say
own a mistake potentially i think was
powerful
and also just kind of we have a lot of
great people
and players in a clubhouse that we're
gonna be denied and
um yeah it's not easy when a
championship
and and you know as well with anybody
and so the kind of the players how we're
playing some luck's got to be involved
and
again we just weren't going to be
tonight this year all right so let's
move to game six then dave roberts
manager of the los angeles dodgers here
on the rich eisen show um mookie gave
you a smile when uh on cash lifted snell
huh
did he you guys
so what's your take as the opposing
manager who obviously
uses analytics um in in making decisions
about the the absolute torrent of
criticism that kevin cash is receiving
for removing blake snell
when he did yeah you know what i i think
that the thing is is that um
i i definitely feel bad for for cash
he's a heck of a manager
players play hard for him he understands
the game knows the game
i think in that situation um yeah they
went with something that was kind of
pre-planned that he wasn't going to see
mookie the third time but
but anyone watching the game knows that
you know mookie wasn't seeing him well
no one was seeing well and
the stuff didn't kind of decline as far
as snow and so when he changed the
momentum changed and
we felt good about it every manager has
their own decisions
and things like that but if they don't
work out certainly more criticize than
uh if they do work out so then let me uh
remove
you from the position i just put you in
of coming across as
second-guessing a colleague um and ask
you
what would you rather make a mistake on
uh
an analytics move or a gut and feel move
you know what that's a great question um
i i think i would rather
make a mistake that's a good question
it's a it's a hard one richie because
it's like that there's certain players
that you can
go with your gut with and there's
certain analytics
and you're putting it in a broad bucket
and a wider bucket where the data how
much data you know
so it's a really hard one answer because
i think that i've made mistakes going
with my cut
i've made mistakes going with with the
data
and i think the thing is is that with
the information it's
kind of trying to get ahead of what's
gonna happen which no one knows
and i think in baseball where when i
played let's say i was six or twelve off
somebody that doesn't mean the next 12
at that so i'm gonna hit 500 against
this player but that's the mindset of
the player
and so as a manager you're trying to get
and project what's going to be the next
12 attacks
um so it's a really good that's a really
good debate and i've made mistakes with
both
so then um then let's get to uh what
happened with justin turner
and i appreciate you mentioning earlier
that you knew this was coming
um when did you find out that justin
turner was coveted positive
dave in the seventh inning uh we were
hitting
and i was on the bench and our team
president andrew freeman comes
into that doug on the back part of the
dugout and calling me down so i was like
befuddled obviously and kind of weighs
me down and says we got to get justin
out of the game right now the
commissioner wants him out he tested
positive for covid and so
at that point in time we're all in shock
justin's out of the game i've got to get
edwin rios ready to take third base and
potentially taking it back so that's
what i found out
and then i guess he goes in the train
room and gets kind of quarantined
i'm doing interviews we win it
celebrates on the field there's a team
photo
i ended up joining the photo late uh
sitting next to justin where he was in
the photo
and kind of all heck kind of broke loose
after that yeah what do you make of all
the
the heck that you and the organization
have received dave
about him coming out in the midst of the
pandemic
uh unmasked and so many people were
freaking out i'll be honest
because you are a cancer survivor and
you're sitting there next to him on mask
too
no and i really appreciate those
sentiments but i am the one who chose to
sit next to him um i i think for
all of us uh rich this is something new
to everybody
um this this entire panic so so how to
do things the right way and now you kind
of fake in emotion
we all could have done a better job and
that goes from
major league baseball to the dodgers to
justin to our personnel
i think we could have all done better um
i think for me
i just kind of come from a place of i
just hope and pray
no one contracts the virus justin's fine
i look at what he's done for the city
the game of baseball
and never making anything about himself
and it kind of turned to this
and some of it is his own fault and i
understand that uh not all the sum of it
and um i just hope it kind of passes and
um
we won a championship 32 years uh you
know and and finally
right and so it just unfortunate this is
the talk of the dodgers 2020
championship
but i understand it but hopefully we can
kind of move forward once this kind of
gets settled no i know and and he's not
just any dodger either
you know and i know who he is and what
he stands for and what he means to the
team and the city and what he's done to
make himself
who he is and what a great guy he is and
the fact that he is now
um somebody who is uh the subject
of a criticism is it's unfortunate
but it's also in some ways to be very
honest with you warranted i'm wondering
if there's any
regret um in in the way all this went
down
i think so i think so and i think that's
a fair assessment
um and like i said i i think we could
have all handled it better
um i just think sometimes in this kind
of world
um grace is needed at times and and i
think the body of work the character of
a person
uh the intent and i don't i think should
all be weighed in and i just don't think
justin is getting the grace that he
deserves
um and knowing that that there was
mistakes on a lot of people
on a lot of fronts okay and uh so is
everybody
fine is anybody showing symptoms
we're fine i've tested negative uh
multiple times since that point
um same with uh our coaches as i
understand so
um so so so that's what i'm kind of
hanging my hat on
and hopefully that kind of remains okay
who did you speak to when it was all
over that you hadn't spoken to or was
from your past or
you got a text from somebody anybody a
call that you were like that's pretty
cool
you know what ceo gaston um that was
such a great call that i got and i
remember being in college watching the
blue jays and
uh winning back to back and i played
with robbie aleman and just kind of
seeing him as african-american managers
who wanted
um and for him to kind of watch me from
a farmer
there was a great article in the post
and for him to reach out
by voicemail that was really really cool
i was really
grateful for that one because we have no
connection no tie
outside of you know being black men who
manage major league baseball clubs that
won a championship so um that was really
cool
that is pretty cool ceto gaston who's i
have not heard in quite some time the
wamco blue jays i remember the those
that was what a hell of a team that was
that's pretty cool that he that he
called you
and the other one was sandy koufax so
those two uh
now you buried the lead dave come on
with all your respect to see though
rich danny and i are friends so he's
always there when times are tough when
times are
going well so he's as consistent as they
come so
that was more that was more not expected
i'm very grateful for our relationship
but ceta was like off the radar
i apologize for bearing the lead
it must be so cool look down your phone
it says sandy kofax okay let me take
this call
um that's so cool seriously seriously
that was really really cool
and i will say this danny called me
before he called clayton
so how about that ah that's also a great
humble brag too
hey well thanks for calling in dave i
always appreciate our chats
congrats on the big win and um it's
something that obviously is
is special for the city for you and uh i
appreciate you also calling in
uh even though you you probably missed
it i did have the commissioner on
monday before um before the final game
uh and i do have my fellow uh boston red
sox
friend over there uh chris brockman here
so i tried to get the mookie bets trade
rescinded on his behalf
uh but it did not happen it wasn't
successful you understand you're a
former red sox you understand why i was
attempting that for for christmas i
understand why you're attempting but i
am so
grateful that that that trade did happen
[Laughter]
well enjoy mookie for the next uh
umpteen years and uh and enjoy this
championship thanks for the call dave
and i'm glad you're feeling well
all right rich take care thanks for
having me that's dave roberts la
dodger's manager
championship manager ceto gaston that is
a name i have not heard i haven't heard
norway
sometime good one hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here